المشاهدين سنتحدث عن هذه الازمه
الاقتصاديه في اوكرانيا بالطبع لها اكثر
من وجهها لكن ازمه الحبوب يمكن اختصارها
في شركه عملاقه لهذه الصناعه تدهورت فيها
الامور بحسب تقرير لصحيفه فاينانشل تايمز
البريطانيه الصحيفه قالت ان شركه نبيولون
تراجعت اوضاعها بسبب الحرب بعدما كانت
احدى اكبر شركات الصناعات الزراعيه في
اوكرانيا وفي العالم من مدينه نيكولايف
انطلقت الشركه لحمل ملايين الاطنان من
الحبوب في ناقلات متجهه الى الاسواق
العالميه هذه الشركه كانت جزءا من اعاده
تشكيل اوكرانيا ما بعد الاتحاد السوفيتي
التي اطلق عليها سله خبز العالم القطاع
الزراعي في اوكرانيا كان جزءا مهما من
الاقتصاد الاوكراني مع وجود 14% من السكان
في القطاع الذي يمثل ثلث الناتج المحلي في
اوكرانيا وبعد ان كانت مصدرا لعشرين مليون
طن في الحبوب سنويا ساهمت الشركه بمضاعفه
المحصول ثلاث مرات عام
2021 ومنذ بدء الحرب كان على نبيولان
التكيف مع عدم التصدير من البحر الاسود
وايضا ارتفاع تكاليف النقل ما ادى لانخفاض
الصادرات من مقدار الثلثين خلال العام
الماضي قبل الحرب كان لدى الشركه سته الاف
موظف اما اليوم اربعون بالمئه من موظفيها
لا يستطيعون العمل بسبب التحاقهم بالجيش
او لسكنهم في اراد خاضعه حاليا للسيطره
الروسيه
اهميه هذه الشركه محليا وعالميا وضعت
مؤسسها اوليكسي
على لائحه المستهدفين من قبل روسيا بحسب
ما تقول اوكرانيا ليلقى مصرعه في يوليو
الماضي في قصف على نيكولايف
[موسيقى]